[Musique]
l'iccat et 5 septembre prochain on vous
attend très nombreux à port marly il
faut que les jeunes de ce pays prenne la
parole
beaucoup ont été trouvés par emmanuel
macron il vous avez premier un pays qui
serait accueillant pour vous un pays qui
serait redynamiser en lités on a un pays
aujourd'hui en miettes une dette énorme
qui va peser sur les générations futures
et des jeunes qui n'ont plus d'espoir et
qui ne croient plus malheureusement dans
notre beau pays
notre belle france donc il faut avec les
républicains que vous repreniez la
parole que vous redonner espoir aux
français que vous donniez sport aux
jeunes est avec nous l'élection
présidentielle c'est dans maintenant
moins de deux ans c'est le moment de s'y
préparer et ne pourra pas gagner si on
n'emmène pas avec nous la jeunesse de ce
pays à la charge pour nouer avec vous de
faire naître un nouvel espoir
tout est prêt tout est organisé ces
trésorier et d'un ciel qui vous parle
vous accueillir dans les meilleures
conditions à port marly
c'est à venir lanières de pays c'est le
vôtre c'est le moment pour vous
de prendre la parole de vous exprimer et
construire avec ou canadiens meilleures
glaces
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]